[Music]
see where you were when before i know
where you are now that we go live
because you always swap places but i'm
always on this side so i think that's
because i'm
like the host or i'm always on the
anyway that makes sense welcome to
sidetrack
how are you stormy how are you harris
how you doing
doing well doing well
doing well as well
can't complain
i apologize for a little bit early um
you guys have to get up have your
breakfast and immediately get straight
into this
but
um
england my ladies are playing i've got
someone that's not on my shirt
my ladies are playing at um in an hour
and uh can't wait so come on andrew's
actually joined us and he's in ours
so he has been thanking me most of the
day
for us doing a little bit early so we
can actually i'm not going to have to go
up at four in the morning
to watch us live which he's done before
no
crazy i mean we're good andrew we're not
that good this is like
but thank you so much yeah he's been a
really good supporter of the channel for
ages and ages
so
we are going to have a little bit of a
chat about good acting and then we might
throw in some dodgy acted instagram
crack and star wars and whatever else
anybody you guys you want to throw in uh
it's 1am
thank you there you go man you stick
with us the whole show then no bother
you can't thank you this time it's only
it's like four am just like please stop
talking i want to go to bed
um so we're going to talk about some
crap acting this came about weirdly
stormy you mentioned this you said oh
should we do this video about
good acting and and start star trek and
i spent well harris doesn't know
anything about star wars well after i've
mentioned star wars a bit at least it
was like fine but you then mentioned
um an actor from star trek remember who
you mentioned in your message
uh deforest kelly in the original series
the forest
california which was weird right because
i had just watched uh two or three days
before the undiscovered country
which i'm every i i tell everybody
repeatedly that it's my favorite
original series star trek because i
stuck out of school to go watch it when
i was a kid so i like like two o'clock
in the afternoon and i'm like hiding
from school and like watching on my own
like
13.
um
but um
there's a scene in it though when um
after the um
the chancellor's dead
and
um kirk and bones are in the um court
and wharf's grandson or whatever is like
being the worst lawyer on the planet
um
but he says to him
you you through age or whatever you were
incompetent and you let him die and it
the first kelly just does this because
i was desperate to save him
oh i was gonna save him he was the last
best hope for peace
and that in that movie just went and i
just i
genuinely remember leaning back going
[ __ ] man he can act
yeah god damn he's a good actor um and
then he stood next to william shatner
i was like ah
god damn in contact
it's a little bit
i mean there's uh you know
kelly didn't get i mean he didn't get a
lot of really big monologues throughout
the series or films
but when he did it was um
he really shone i mean he was you know
it was
you couldn't help watch him in the scene
he stole every scene he he had some
really decent dialogue in
uh there was a one
it was uh in uh one of the movies
uh
which one was that it was uh
in search of spock i believe it was yeah
you know they're all either everyone's
going up to uh kirk's condo in san
francisco
and the force kelly brings uh you know
his other present and he's bringing some
scotch and he just casually walks
across the room with the drink in his
hand you know talking about you know
you know goddamn we're not celebrating
your death here you know he has a
monologue
and it's really short but it the quality
the way he delivered it
and the way he just you know
kind of got into himself as a character
as you can walk across the room with the
in the anxious if you could ever hold
the glass anxiously he grabbed the glass
anxiously
and delivered that line and it's just
those little snippets you know he
i think what do you think harrison i'm
just all full of [ __ ] what this
morning
it's very
well versed in the star trek but i i if
you can grab a drink anxiously and
depict that you're acting well
you can you can kind of add a little
physicality to it you know but not too
much because over doing it it's very
easy trying to be anxious
yeah
you know like just dropping things at
that point but uh
if you can hold that back you're a good
actor that's that's 100 direct truth
the bit i like is it's the worst star
trek movie when they want wandered off
to find god
um
damaging we don't ask god for his
driving license
um that was good but but the actual
early when they meet sarak for the first
time just sarah isn't
spock's brother
um and they um
cyborg the dad sucks at that doesn't it
gotta mix them up
getting ready i thought he was gonna say
sarah in there for a minute and i said
hey buddy
um
but yeah but he they do this quick when
they meet um cyborg for the first time
and who sounds like he should be about
galactica to me but anyway um
and you know he's he uses his powers to
sort of like bring memories from their
past in that bit of the movie and
lennon and leonard nimoy does a bit and
then bill shatner's but watch that scene
don't watch this film because the rest
of the film is bloody awful but watch
that scene for deforest kelly it's i
mean there should be awards
it's just because the rest of the movie
is so bad people forget really but that
that is a powerful scene
um the whole bit around the campfire
starts good as well but anyway yeah so
we thought we'd have a chat about who
are the you know
what what of acting in star trek star
wars any other sci-fi guys you want to
get into the comments and tell us about
or you guys think of or
when when is like an actor really blown
you away um and i was and i've i've done
myself a little bit of a list but also
one of actors maybe not so good because
i think we've mentioned harris earlier i
mentioned
um bill shatner some of our favorites
bill shatner and mark campbell
yeah well
both these actors
are
questionable
at times for their ability to act
william shatner is actually capable of
doing some really good stuff um
but maybe that's something like you
mentioned harris about how if you can do
so anxiously but you just if you
slightly overdo it it ruins it and i'm
thinking about like that twilight zone
movie episode sorry when um bill will
shatner's in there and the the the
things on the on the plane
yeah yeah yeah
bits of that he's fantastic
but then in a moment you'll just ever
slightly overdo it you're just like oh
no there's william shatner that we oh
there he is i forgot
sometimes i wonder if uh
shatner is
really a good actor but i think at least
in track he was just really stylized
he had a way of speaking you know and
it's not really over it's just that was
his style i mean it's his style it's
just it's a style of acting
and you know like every sentence has an
exclamation point
and it's
d i mean you know what i mean harris i
mean he was just like
because he's completely different in all
like the westerns he was in and like you
said twilight zone you
legal boston legal is one of my favorite
shows him and james spader i love that
show and and williamstown was great in
it
played a nutter
i'm sorry how are you great things no no
you can do great things if you can find
that character and i guess you can you
can lose the character as well going
into
trying to be too human and
overdoing an emotion i guess on camera
uh
it's like don't don't try to look you
too human just just be human and do your
thing you know
yeah uh i think i think you can
generally do well but
sometimes that within that style you can
lose or or gain traction yeah it happens
heavily on both sides sometimes
dwayne the rock johnson has the
emotional range of a peanut butter
and john cena is really bad as well i
love him and he's i think i said what is
the difference
i'll ask you guys what's the difference
between a libel actor and a good actor
or is there a difference
because i would say john cena the rock
they're likeable actors
yeah good at their craft yeah so yeah
okay i gotta where's my imdb tab
there's one actor great actor
he
hated him
let me remember this the other day i
mean it was uh
what was that little guys thing uh no no
no
no
michael emerson
who played the character ben linus on
lost
the little guy he was like dead of the
the others
you know i lost you know does take you
away back to 2006 i admit but
he was so good i mean he was a he is a
great actor
oh yes i do know oh my god did you just
want to shoot him in the head with a gun
i mean because he was so
manipulative and evil and self-centered
and obnoxious
as as
as he portrayed his character he was
just
you know you just wanted to burn his
house down but so i mean he's a good
actor but my god did you hate him he's
really good if you want to commit arson
for him i mean means he's done his job
well he's done it right
i think some of the great actors though
you can have characters where you just
hate them because gary oldman is one of
the greatest actors of our generation
yeah virtually every part is everything
i detest him but because
you're supposed to
um
i was thinking about this with um
kenneth branagh he's he's
he's one of my favorite actors of this i
think he's one of the greatest actors
that's ever lived but he did this movie
with him he played a nazi
and he was so
detestable he was
pleasant all the way through and it's it
it makes you want to scratch sort of
things like god he's just how can a
human being like this exist
um you know what i mean and
kenneth bryant absolutely freaking
nailed it
um he was terrified about that role
um the
final solution i think it was cool
final solution they were all trying to
figure out what to do with the jews
and
he was
god he was just flat out evil and he
would he he was in such a
dangerous sugary mixture of
kind to everybody else unless you got on
this bad side and then the daggers came
out and he and because no one could
constrain him except the fur
he he was just
he made me nervous watching i mean
you're talking about an actor getting an
emotional response out of it kenneth
branagh can do but then you see kenneth
browner in um
harry potter
yeah
even though he was a bad guy in that
he's just i don't i love kenneth brown i
just think he's he's just the greatest
actor
yeah
but you know in the final solution he
was not a bubble uh bumbling
villain not really yeah no he was like
he was like a razor blade
yeah have you seen murder on the orient
express or death on the nile yes yes
yes i mean peter yustenov is prairie
even though he's the least like prairie
from the books peter yusunov is pro for
me but um but when when i heard kenneth
branagh was doing it
i love his betrayal he's
the movies aren't necessarily the best
in the freaking world but
i can watch him all day just because
bran egg is in there and he has a good
cast with them all the time
and that mustache
um it well it is magnificent and the the
whole thing with the eggs and are just i
just love although the little things
they brought from the book that they've
never had in the movies before and again
a thoroughly dislikable character but
it's kenneth branagh so yeah what are
you gonna do
how about just like likable actors and
do you have like likeable actors that
you think
that the that it doesn't matter that
there may be
that they're just playing themselves a
lot of the time that they're just
reading the lines and does it matter
i honestly say that depends on the actor
because you do have your rocks and you
have your john cena's but then you also
have your mark wahlberg's who play
themselves typically all the time
but he's also i believe oscar nominated
because you just give him the right role
and he can run with it uh
mark wahlberg departed still it's one of
my favorite things i've ever seen
honestly yeah um
and a few others
but yeah
that kind of
there's
it's almost like uncanny valley with cgi
but with acting ability sometimes right
uh is where i guess that likeability can
really change and it does depend on
the material they're working with all
the time
like shatner can can be great and he can
be not so great mark hamill can be
the joker and be doing the best voices
ever and he can also
deliver in a great cheesy star wars line
that might not be the best but we'll
remember for a long time you know
by the way the film we were talking
about uh brana in the in the united
states it was called conspiracy so if
you're wanting to see it okay i think
it's streaming off of hbo and it's
conspiracy with uh brenna and stanley
tushie so conspiracy
two shoes um
oh and the british guy in it that's in
it whose name
has gone out my head i can see his face
he was in the um
the king's the kingsman film where the
very st
old guy
no no oh fine not mark strong i like
kenneth and vanner in valkyrie as well
he was fantastic valkyrie andrews just
mentioned
and and our marvel buddy tom hiddleston
was also the phone operator in
conspiracy
no way
cool okay so you mentioned actors that
play themselves is jeff goldblum a good
actor or is jeff goldblum just jeff
goldblum
so i would say no
because okay so it on apple plus i know
you haven't seen it
there
jeff goldblum has a show being jeff
goldblum doing his documentaries and
jeff goldblum is so over the top jeff
goldblum in his own show that it really
does separate jeff goldblum from like
the jurassic park
uh jeff goldblum or you know the fly
jeff goldblum
or even independence
if you really want you some jeff
goldblum in your life apple tv to get
the
disney in the uk
just picture of him in his glasses just
do something down his glasses but
i've always thought because he he does
he's he's a well-respected actor i mean
other actors say like that's how you do
everything and i've seen him in um that
he has adhd a hundred percent i've seen
him in the interview he's mental
um and he just turns it back but that's
great for
i think he's a great actor but i think
he just plays jeff goldblum
yeah but
talk about star trek though then like so
we got forrest kelly who we thought was
a great actor we got william shatner we
thought
how about leonard nimoy
because i mean
there are scenes
as spock that obviously is a very
withdrawn character but when he goes
crazy he goes properly crazy but
particularly the movies
he did some
pretty impressive emotional scenes
you know he was i was i had a lot of
respect for leonardo dimay just as a
filmmaker he also made the best star
trek movies when he was involved in the
actual production they were good
yeah
when he didn't have roddenberry yelling
at him i mean he did a much better job
of spot
what i know leonard nimoy i love
everything i've ever seen him in i i
can't complain
yeah if he hasn't got pointy ears and
shaved his eyebrows so it's just creeped
me out i've seen a few westerns and
things
fantastic as well um you know that's
where a lot of these guys came from but
if we get into the tvc the more modern
tv series and because i mean that was
one of the things when tng the next
generation came out was just like people
like who's this british guy pretended to
be french he's like stage actor rubbish
and gene roddenberry really went for
they said no patrick stewart is the man
um
he's got to he's got to be the captain
he's he's going to be and obviously
we've seen his acting ability no one's
going to question his patrick she wasn't
a good actor
but is that important
i started i has it sir pat's do you
very
paddy does just a series particularly
something that like star wars star trek
because when we talk about the
mandalorian things like there's also the
acting in in some of the star wars
is it really important that you need
one or two really good actor to sort of
hang your hat on for series like that to
to carry
you have to yeah
but so like
you gotta have somebody to carry the
show i mean you
um
for whatever reason netflix has a lot of
shows and movies
uh from the foreign films where no one
is carrying the show i mean it is just
you know the neighbor's dog has more
personality than the lead character
you know and i never get past episode
one or the first 10 minutes of the movie
you have to have an actor that can
emotionally gauge the audience
and keep them nailed in their seat you
know and um wow
it's like i i can't remember her name
but the first uh captain janeway that
they hired for uh voyager
was just kind of phoning it in just kind
of reading lines really could not engage
and so what they shot one or two
episodes with her then had to read yeah
yeah they've been shot for about three
weeks
was it three weeks
i and i don't know how far they got with
the episodes but yeah she was there
three weeks and then she said that's a
similar story to where michael j fox
isn't it with them back to the future
that they've said there was nothing
wrong
with the actor that they initially had
for back to the future he was a great
actor ginger fellow whose name's gone on
my head
um
it was really good there's nothing wrong
with it and they said the same for
voyaging there's nothing wrong with this
it's just not
it's just not
i couldn't quite put the thing and kate
mulgrew came in
and smashed another park again came
straight from stage she was a stage
actress yeah
that's what sometimes you need that type
of if you don't have like the big name
actor or something that has that all
that experience to help ground
everything stage actors can be that kind
of grounding kind of piece yeah mulgrew
and stewart man i mean they definitely
brought it
uh if you've ever watched uh
mulgrew in orange is the new black
you know her portrayal of the uh russian
mob wife
okay it's just
she's but she has some comedy chops
there but also a lot of sympathy there
great great
yeah great portfolio
but then i think from like the next
generation you've got somebody like
brent spiner
who
don't get me wrong he can act but that's
not his background he he came from sort
of like stage but he was a performer
you know he's dancing a singer you know
he did all this something
um
you need that ensemble though don't you
you need that thing i i would argue at
times but
brent spain is not the greatest actor in
the world
um
all the emotional stuff with data was
not always great
but he was
but he was so likable and so you know we
we all loved him but he had such she had
other talents then you got something
like jonathan frakes and i'm sorry he
couldn't act for toffee
um
i don't but he fit his role
you know yeah yeah
it's like i don't know if you guys
remember but uh spiner
is after he's like during the last
couple seasons of uh next gen or maybe
after
he uh he had these old um well he had an
album he had a musical album out and uh
i think he was the title was old yellow
eyes or old gold eyes and it was it was
really cool um
kind of
you know 50s vegas swing
it was really [ __ ] cool
you know annie played a lounge singer in
uh uh patrick stewart's comedy i think
it ran one season or two seasons blunt
or blunt
yeah it was on uh it was on
stars i think it was and he just played
this toss-off role you know just as a
lounge singer
with a piano oh my god he was great in
that he just
and sometimes
and i think
talking about the ensemble thing and
data being kind of you know
well you know you know thrusters on
capitol whatever
yeah a lot of times when you have really
good actors
and then you have some sort of acting
god like stuart everybody else seems
really kind of mellow and just phoning
it in because then you're you know the
baseline becomes the whoever the really
the big star the big talent and everyone
else is kind of reduced because you're
looking at their differences
you know
and it's like you know uh they they all
may be shining but the big ass bright
dude in the middle
telling you to engage is overshining
everybody else the other talents don't
show through
all based on their merit do you think
that's because they're really the only
character that's truly fleshed out where
everybody else is that they're fleshing
them out over time but they kind of come
in as more of a character of a character
and kind of work their way into actually
almost becoming human where like really
the first bits of most seasons of things
are focusing and like delving in on a
particular person or things like that
yeah i would agree with that because if
you listen to their commentaries
you know and the other actors
commentaries
well you know i had to write out what my
character was you know he did this he
was in there he liked it whatever
you know and you don't hear that from
stewart who had everything already
planned
like you said you know it was they knew
who stuart was and they knew who they i
think they had more developmental
material on cue
than they did any other cast member
besides uh stewart
you know
i have to understand who this person is
sort of thing to be able to do it
something yeah um
no i okay i hundred percent get that do
you sometimes get like when acting is so
bad though but but it doesn't matter if
the project isn't i'm the first starship
troopers
i was thinking about
for sure and okay starship troopers
starship troopers is is is some of the
worst acting
um
i mean
honestly casper van diene is such a bad
actor there's no shock that he's had
very little career since
um but he's so bad
i mean i mean literally
i mean you'd want to poke your eyes out
rather than watch
him in actually anything serious but it
didn't matter because the film was
ridiculous
and the money was spent on the effects
rather than the actors they literally
hired a bunch of actors that would too
are you available fine come on
um you know everybody else was kind of
mediocre you know but michael ironside
you know the he started out as the
school teacher the veteran and then
ending up you know running the
roughnecks and it was
he really i mean he he he took i think
he took the job seriously and he really
delivered his lines i mean
he was the compelling character i think
you know
and he was the only name wasn't he
almost like the guy they actually spent
the money on something that we will
actually pay for him because he has got
an important role you have to care when
he dies as well which is important let's
be honest if
if rico had died in starship troopers
you'd have been grateful
um it would have been god
stop talking
but when
yeah when he dies it's like
it's ironside dies it's like we actually
don't know [ __ ] like we actually cared
so yeah that makes sense and getting
getting
people to actually care about a
character is insanely hard yes you know
to get that emotional connection you've
got to be able to act and
um so
can i ask a question that made me think
real quick
while we're talking about ensembles and
like
the the good actors and bad actors and
likeable actors and these things
what about the mandalorian particularly
season one because they do have some
larger named actors to kind of ground
their work like nick nolte
i have spoken you know uh uh and uh carl
weathers is grief cargo of course yeah
and i personally like her but uh we we
don't need to delve too far into her but
gina carano is not the best actress in
the world and then pedro pascal is also
not
in in the show for the most part most of
the time that brings us back to like
physicality as an actor as well because
that's john wayne's grandson that i
believe is in the in
that makes sense that okay john wayne's
grandson knows physicality that's kind
of half of what they do
um
[Music]
but it's it's just an interesting kind
of that that almost we didn't get that
entire character we have to learn about
each character along the way yeah which
i think helps that series a lot
and somehow they keep us you know even
though we don't have that big
grinding supernova of an actor begin
with
um
you know
the the the guy that's actually doing
the suit even though pascal's doing the
voiceovers through it we're watching it
through the physicality you know and how
um like the emotion that the uh
the suit driver for lack of a better
term is actually
connecting with the audience yeah pat
skelton was there sure
i thought he was putting hell in the
suit for
i thought jean favreau insisted that it
had to be him in the suit
no
not him they they said
for the first two seasons it was less
than like 10 of uh footage and for the
filming the third season he had no
principal photography at all
wow okay who knows if he's even going to
take his helmet off this season uh but
he's also filming of course the last of
us and all that so he's busy
he's busy boy busy boy
yeah but as long as we have john wayne's
grandson bringing that that's that's why
it feels so well
well like western and stuff is because
he's walking
and it's john wayne's grandson you know
you're in a western the second he enters
the screen that's great yeah space
western
that's subtle a subtlety um a timothy
fountain season two for me is is
is ultimately um as i was booker bob
effect wasn't it sorry but um he's just
he plays a cool
a cowboy
so barry lowen barry lowen john wins
your answer very low and is his name
oh okay
oh cool
i actually like i know people dislike um
uh
cara dune um a gina
character and she's not going to be
appearing but i've really liked i liked
her and everything she's done and
because she comes in again no she's not
the greatest actress in the world but
she comes out with a fizz i think it's a
shame when they don't use it to be
honest and what she's good at is she get
her in get her to punch someone
yeah so that's what she's there for
doesn't matter she can't actually we've
got other people to act you know
i think she just punched herself in the
face too many times you know on twitter
and instagram
yeah
i mean it wasn't just one instance that
got her fired it was
you know first you know she was a uh
trumpster and just making all sorts of
unsubstantiated claims then she went to
whole unvaccinated route you know all
vaccines are [ __ ] it's 5g i mean
she's spewing all this [ __ ] on twitter
right
and disney kept you know interact said
look you you are representing the show
you're representing you know you're
representing you know star wars you're
representing disney you've got to cut
this [ __ ] out you know and they've
talked to her publicist and then she
went
you know
she went all holocaust deniers and said
that you know the um it wasn't the uh
the nazis that was beating up the jews
it was children
and at that point disney had had enough
it was huh
when she say that
she just compared republicans
plight to uh to the jews plate
oh she did that too
it was a long longer list but once she
got to the the nazis never beat up the
jews it was children
uh that is when
disney threw up their hands and said
[ __ ] you you're no longer in a series
goodbye now we need to check your mind
but it wasn't just one instance it was a
long tumultuous relationship between
disney her pr
people trying to sit on her and get her
to you know stop being such an asshat
and at some point time didn't it just
the the whole
holocaust denial which
everyone's sensitive to except i think
her
i i don't remember seeing anything about
the denial but yeah i've actually got a
clip of it before she deleted it
someplace it's it was included a picture
i saw it on instagram i said oh this is
not gonna go good for her so i snapchat
no
it doesn't work
um i just think anybody if anybody that
just says uh
comparing anything to the plight of the
jews you're in immediately in in a
troubled area
um
personally you know it's like things
like sierra leone and other places all
over the world this has some horrific
moments those people can go well this is
a bit like what the jews went through
nobody else can
yeah um if you've you know unless unless
half of your family has been slaughtered
in um in some sort of things you have no
right to even put the words in your
mouth as well but anyway
let's move on let's let's keep it light
should we people yeah
so
who's your next good or bad actor we're
talking about conspiracy
i want to talk about conspiracy theories
in star wars
okay
liam neeson right so when liam neeson
did
take a movie do you know why i was so
excited about it i was just like damn
it's an action movie with somebody that
can actually act
it would be awesome and it was it was
awesome i mean he's now he went out to
become an action star someone not sure
what that happened but um but it was
awesome
liam neeson is a great actor he's crap
in style in the first star wars movies
i thought he was terrible i have
re-watched it recently and i i am biased
i'm pretty fond of it of course but
he's
he does
him and you and mcgregor are by far the
best part of the whole film uh yeah and
of course you have the two of them on a
screen that probably gonna be the best
parts of the film
um
and even though it's it's it's
it's pretty
wooden dialogue and things like that he
does really well with everything he does
portray i think generally
it's
it's what he's got
i saw i saw a meme with that not long
ago and it said um
uh it's had a shot of like annie coming
out of the ship after blowing it up and
killing
tens of thousands of people and going
woo-hoo
is the bad guy
i committed mass home on the side yay me
whew
first of many plus he had r2d2 with him
for the first time there who also goes
on to commit many uh mass uh murders
those are the two most
those star wars characters the two that
have killed more than anybody else
murder in a can that's all right chopper
is the only other droid that's killed
more
we'll do a star wars video next week if
we um if we do if we do a video on
sunday um
i wouldn't mind doing a star wars video
was those first three the three
chronologically the first three why on
earth did they bring r2d2 and c3p into
those films
i think that could be a long
conversation what the f were they
thinking
it just made it complicated
stuff surely
that's just got to be because george
lucas loved kenny baker and uh uh
oh my god
c3 anthony his first name is anthony go
on and uh
anthony
anthony i know it's just a brain fart uh
come on
i love it when people say bragging
thought all right i have them every day
talk about an 80d
yeah i love a good brain fart anthony
daniels
there we go there we go
i can't look it up i was hoping
somebody's gonna say in the chat but i
beat him to it thankfully
i've got my star wars cred
there we go thanks matt
he's he's he's googling like crazy today
um and trust me he uh honest yes matt
dean and so
he doesn't know these things he did a
quiz once for me and he doesn't know
anything
so but he said he'll be googling like
mad and you're that matt admit it
i'm gonna be at the ready
i'll tell you what though um
one we know something about sci-fi and
actors my first book was avery brooks
um
and ds9
but
uh and you have to have an education in
ds9 we we appreciate that he did google
he's a liar um so
but dear
avery brooks in the first couple of
series wasn't i didn't particularly like
him as an actor i thought he's he's he
didn't hold himself very well he's like
he didn't quite know that who the
character was and it's only when
um cisco started to get pissed off
and the dark side started coming through
that you realize you're how good an
actor every brooks source yeah
and and it's particularly in something
but as soon as he shaved his head
he got and he only shaved his head
because he was appearing in a movie with
him
as hawk
for uh
oh i've forgotten the characters i've
got the shows the show
anyway ds9 had a really good ensemble i
mean there's lots of characters you know
you think
about uh who's best but and you're right
when um
cisco in the later seasons when
tensions on the station got bigger and
he had to protect his son more
uh did he really shine you know um
you know i always say that the deep
space nine was really not a star trek uh
series it was really his best show about
uh a father and son relationship i mean
by far
but there was
so many actors there i think somebody uh
mentioned it over in chat a little bit
it was whoever played
uh
goldicott
yes they did very good act god um
played uh
marco
great actor in my favor man the one i
actually think stole everything
stole everything was the uh actor play
garrick
yeah
i'm gonna have a look at him just too
quickly because he he deserves his name
ready i'll be showing us was um he was a
really good actor as well
uh where is he where is he where is he
andrew robinson fred
he played psychos in so many movies over
the years he was just mental
um
he has not passed away he's still alive
he's yeah he
did not know ah that's where i learned
from them
harry
and dirty harry
which was just
he played an amazing psycho in that
movie he's just got one of those faces
it's a shame he's behind all the makeup
really because he didn't realize who he
was
but um
now he was a phenomenal actor um the
most versatile andrew robinson didn't
say his name sorry
the most versatile and deep space nine
has to be jeffrey combs
yep because i mean like
yeah how many characters did he play he
played brunt
you know he played wei yoon's he played
all the way ins uh he's also played uh
commander shrek in enterprise but that
one i mean he was i mean and you don't
really
he's so good at differentiating the
different uh characters is they really
don't
they don't remind you of everything else
he's done like when he does
you know shrek you know uh
brunt brunt is so different than wei
yoon you really i mean it was a while
before i caught on it was the same guy
because the well that was star trek i
know they got an actor they like just
goes well with makeup how many different
parts can you play all of them
all right
well jeffrey crews may have legend i saw
something i think jeffrey coons played
nine characters in star trek i want to
say
i did this in a quiz question so i
should know but i think it's nine but he
appeared without makeup a couple of
times he appeared in the one where
they're on the hollow deck and they're
in like the um
in the in the swinging 20s in the thing
he was wanted like a waiter or something
well he he also he played uh when uh
cisco was uh kind of had that orb
experience
kind of
went back and he was a writer back in
the new york
uh
uh in uh
trying to write the story ds9 or deep
space nine that was the story trying to
make it this publisher
uh the bad cop there's two bad props you
know one was jeffrey combs
yeah and also if you consider again
harris you never know what we're talking
about but he played a character called
wyoon who was actually a um they used to
genetically engineer them so they were
like they were they were copies so it
says um so the question the question was
how many characters jeffrey were you in
play jeffrey coombs play and i think the
answer is nine because or
about 30 something if you include all
the different weigh-ins that he played
because then they would die and they
would just be a new way
most of those weren't even part of the
nine
no no it was just like if if you
necessarily say if it's whether you say
wyon is one character or not or whether
you include all the uh
genetically genetic copies that used to
just come up the um i said what i'm
looking for when you
genetically copy somebody
my brain
clowns thank you sometimes
my brain that's a brain fart
i need that thing to eat ice cream dig a
spoon yes
um but yeah it's like uh and martok ah
martak by jt think he's he played loads
of different characters as well yeah um
10 minutes for each question he was yeah
tell us his question we'll have a quiz
but um but yeah ah it's just
there's there's some really really great
acting in there i like nina sierra tour
as well uh no is that a name nina
visitor sorry
oh man oh
and we've forgotten the greatest actor
from the star trek the next generation
and deep space nine he's one of the
the finest actors ever to appear in any
star trek
call meaning
he's a great
proper irish fellow you'd never know it
again harris no [ __ ] clue what we're
talking about you know what one of the
best films i i the film i liked him the
most in washington trek film is um
uh the title was something like uh i
walked up a hill and came down a
mountain
yeah yeah he was the bartender at the
end right
and i thought he even though he didn't
have a really pivotal it was like
he's played gangsters in a couple of
movies and i'll tell you what
i know he's only an actor but i i
wouldn't disagree with him
he comes probably comes over as um as
terrifying uh
yes he was a great bad guy in stargate
atlantis as well um
if there's a leader of a
terror organization or something
remember but yeah great in that
i saw someone say that ming not win is
in stargate universe yes she was yeah
really yeah yeah
and she just accidentally ended up going
through the gate
um but yeah she didn't play a massive
part in it she was
she could have came in and out of it a
little bit we didn't realize how amazing
she was really until she went into a
sincere shield i don't think
and um that that one was in it
with her voice ioa officer that was
right
yeah but oh she's just she's she's great
enough and i love her so much she was in
her two and a half men
and she was she played like um she was
supposed to be an older woman for
charlie then she's supposed to be in her
40s and that was like the big thing that
she's an older woman i'm like jesus
christ that was over 20 years ago
yeah and she's still playing in agents
of shield she's playing people that are
dating 30 year olds
yeah oh man i've cut off my finger
i i saw her at comic-con this past uh la
comic-con in december of i think yeah of
21.
it was just fun her and giancarlo
esposito who is one of those great
villainous people that we were kind of
talking about earlier
uh
good lord they're just
they're just as good off screen as they
are on screen they're just fun to watch
they're just fun to listen to you too
gotta love a good book
think about that from like from like
sci-fi
one name jumps to mind immediately
an actor that's played just like
an insane villain and not just star trek
whatever just any anything off top of
your head um because you've got like
um james jones his voice and things like
that but just just a great villain from
a sci-fi movie
i said the first thing that jumped into
my head was rutger hauer
um
but yeah he was he was terrifying in
that film um
but you guys could anything jump to mind
with you anything
great villainous bad guy
villainous bad guy in sci-fi
they just named off all the ones i would
really have gone to so look what
universe
whatever you think raphael just from
look wise and of course i'm i'm i grew
up with the animated clone wars tv
series as well
and that's where talk about someone that
comes back into uh an ip and just plays
around a bunch sam whitwer
uh dude do you recognize sam whitworth
he did all the force unleash and all
that he's
he's
he's darth maul in star wars the clone
wars but he's five other characters
throughout star wars as well he's either
he's the voice of the emperor of
palpatine a couple of times as well
he's uh phenomenal and and i think he
flushed out darth maul into a
fantastic villain
yeah
uh the other should just point out that
it's ball for me
ball from stargate
is he's a lovable rogue and i give you
that but it's got to love the actor i
have to google his name in a second but
oh it's just i just love it
but i i'd still say if you don't have a
good villain in a series
it's only ever going to be a good series
you can never be a great show don't have
a great villain
um
i'm trying to think of any other stuff
from like older movies maybe where
there's just been a great villain in it
i mean like like terminator 2 um yeah
robert
uh robert patrick
yeah
great villain brilliant actor there's a
reason why he's still still around now
he's the reason runyon canyon's so busy
over here you can't get a good hike in
hollywood anymore because he uh he's the
reason it got popular back in the day
damn it i know
uh yeah
i i i see you're gonna have to tell me
if this is a proper villain that you're
talking about that really
kind of uh
fits the mold but the replicators
in stargate i thought it was
terrifying i mean yeah they were just
robots right but i thought
they they do have the ability to drum up
fear
you know
i'm i'm surprised being a star wars fan
though
harris all the way through
i mean
particularly if you want to know the
first three christopher lee
oh oh don't get me started count dooku
is my favorite star wars character you
don't even have to that there we go
i love anything christopher lee that
i've never heard that a cattle prod
um and i'm gonna have to look up his
name he's just gonna annoy me because
he's got this his name is very similar
he's he always played
christopher lewis played dracula and
this guy always played um
[Music]
uh
the the hunter uh
come on where are you where are you
uh peter cushing
oh peter cushing from the first one and
obviously they brought it back cgi'd him
for
um one of the new ones didn't he
um
we're talking about how you bring in
good actors for a project
you know i mean dear god if you've got a
project and you've got
you know alec guinness alec guinness
hated star wars he thought it was stupid
but he did so well
but
but the genius was that um
uh you know like the directors that
produced everybody else they knew yeah
let's bring it in because he will be
amazing and uh let's give this some a
bit this project a bit of weight
that's something that can actually act
and then to not just find a way to
i i really like i still need to watch
light and magic that just came out but i
love that george lucas didn't find
another person to bring in for empire
strikes back and was like all right
we'll bring alec guinness back as a
ghost and then
he was a creature to turn onto and like
and get enriched by and it worked it
worked way too well
we got yoda
so uh
thank you allegiance thank you frank oz
yeah just for normal acting but then
you've got
there's always that it's just like
how do you stand on
um
i forgot i forgot his name he's not the
most famous actor in the history
harrison ford
what do you send in harrison ford a
great actor or likable actor that that
connect
in the original trilogy
would you say harris hard anyways i'm
going fantastic that's all
harrison ford i can sum it up there
okay
yeah i i i was going to say that uh of
the the the original three or episode
four five and six
i thought harrison was probably the best
actor in in the lens with the exception
of alec guinness
with the end you know but
concerning the whole original trilogy it
had to be harrison ford because geez
i mean you know when
like the little clips like when he's uh
first got on the death star
and he's sitting you know in the chair
in that little room above the millennium
falcon
and he's on in the storm troopers outfit
and he's just
so
emotive and
disgusted and thinking that everyone's
crazy he doesn't have to say the words
you know what he's thinking and i
thought that was
he's the number one i mean just little
scenes like that you know just like
the force
his talent throughout
i've always wondered if
without harrison ford if the star wars
movies would have had the success
they they obviously the phenomenal
because i i was the the bit in when he
then gets frozen in the in the thing and
that's a really weak bit of the movie
and you're just waiting for harrison
ford to come back i wasn't anyway
harrison ford was the
was the reason why i like star wars
um because it was just phenomenal um and
i like the light sabers and i like the
ships and everything but i mean
would it have been successful
in the originals you know concerning the
the the cultural impact of star wars had
on everybody back in 77
you know if there was another competent
actor there i think no one would have
noticed because everything else was so
over the top and we were shocked by
everything the the story the special
effects the music
you know
even if they got somebody else that was
competent
as hair as you know playing solo
i don't think anybody would have noticed
yeah as long as i could play like a good
scoundrel uh yeah we just got something
special with harrison ford playing space
harrison ford right right right yeah oh
he know he played the scoundrel
brilliant
all of them could and gary oldman is
terrifying in the fifth element but he's
very terrifying in every
going back to the villains if i can't
use the replicators there's another
stargate villain and he didn't have a
lot of screen time but he really just
kind of creeped me out that was julian
sands as the doci
oh yes you know i mean he i mean he was
the the the the makeup and just the big
wall of flame behind me he was just
really creeped me out
mm-hmm
yeah i i did
they had a lot of really good villains
in yeah
and stargate to be fair and star trek
over the years have had some great
feelings i mean we never mentioned khan
god
great
um weird fake chest i think um but just
just benedict cumberbatch was your
favorite con right
no
i'll walk off now i'm kidding
i'll punch you in the nuts
i'd love to come back
i'm a combo [ __ ] all day i think he's a
phenomenal actor he's one of the great
actors we've got of our generation right
now
he was awful in that film
um but i blame jay bree abrams for it
because i blame jb abrams for most of
the things that are wrong in my life i
stubbed my toe on a rock i'll go abram
i blame him for everything that's wrong
in the world i mean he could have had a
company called good robot but you know
he's not he had to go with the bad
[Music]
you know
jj abrams knows what he did in he knows
why i hate him sir star trek star wars
pretty much everything he's ever done
don't
yeah
the star trek movies i've said this a
million times
there
your tree knocked it out of the park
uh-huh they're entertaining movies
they're just not star trek
so just [ __ ] leave it
anyway
so
we
we knocked that one out of the parking
lot good actually
fun
what you've been watching this weekend
for you've got five minutes and three
seconds oh my gosh so my uh resident
evil i'm still hanging there with in
there with resident evil foreign
umbrella academy this week
the the the first episode dance off was
still probably just it was incredible
um
and that and i've been for my uh what
what i call my fill in bench you know
something you just i can't always put
something on television um re-watching
deep space nine again
good man good man harris stop watching
these faces now
i need to i gotta finish
season three i haven't watched it in
like six months so don't kill me but i i
need to finish
season three of sg-1 i'm literally two
episodes after like when the bounty
hunter comes in for the first time right
i just watched the bounty hunter episode
for the i just watched it i'm desperate
to finish it i just i don't know it used
to be like my lunch show and now as when
i started doing like the play a few
months ago i just kind of got out of the
habit of it and i got it you're so lucky
though because you get to watch all
these for the first time it makes me so
happy i i'm slow about it because i
tweet whenever i watch a new episode
just to kind of have like a catalog for
myself and it helps me grow it really
well
this just works
from episode one i it's of course a
little cheesy 90s things every now and
then but you can tell brad wright is
putting stuff in place for future things
and that
makes me happy i love the world
yeah he is
it's just you're so lucky though i just
i i was you not just because you're good
looking and you've got great hair
just because i just i wish i could
delete stargate from my brain and watch
it again
it's so much fun
that's how i figured out about your
channel as i was like all right i need
to learn more about this
lucky bastard
um
what you've been watching this week then
other than star game
i went and saw a question and answer
with the writers for marcel the shell
with shoes on which is a new indie film
that came out this
officially came out this past week it's
been out for two weeks in la and new
york and i should have seen it but
eventually got to it and that was
the most like adorable endearing kind of
film if you need to go see something
with your wife kids bring bring them
it's perfect
uh
it's just really it's stop motion and
it's about a shell that
has kind of lost their family and he's
gotta
go seek them out he watches 60 minutes
with his grandma so he has to get 60
minutes to come in and help him it's a
whole it's great it's just one of those
little things that makes your heart feel
good but uh
besides that i've
been keeping up with what we do in the
shadows
which i adore that's such a great uh tv
show i don't know if y'all seen any of
what we do in the shadows but that that
gets you a little uh fun fantasy comedy
going
i'm halfway through the previous season
i've gotten up to there
three right or two whatever we're on
he's on four we're on four we're four
because i'm halfway through season three
yes okay and it's just it's just
hysterical he's like
season three is miramo
worthy gem yeah gizmo
it's so great season three ends
you're gonna you're gonna be very
shocked you'll love it okay uh
besides that
jay oh i keep saying it on twitter and
then
i i forget to mention it here but i i
love only murders in the building
and i love recruiters now i've seen your
tweet
we have tweeted i love that show and ah
steve martin though steve martin and i'm
not a massive fan of martin short but i
love martin shortens d mine together
i'm really glad uh martin short has
started acting again yes
yeah i hope you want to create
yeah and he's he's good in the most
things he doesn't remember he did the um
santa claus 3 with tim allen um and he
played jack frost and he was just he was
martin short in it but he was great but
i love um
did you watch the netflix special with
martin shorten steve martin when they're
just talking about how they've known
each other for years and they do some of
the comedy bits and things and that that
was great one bit was then he's doing um
steve martin was the ventriloquist and
um martin short was the dummy and it was
just it's actually genuinely cry funny
but the best bits they were talking
about how they met and stuff like they
were doing the three amigos and then
they're there whichever chase and
neither of them particularly like chevy
chase
yeah and selena gomez and um but um
they were playing poker with chevy chase
and um
and steve martin was dealing and steve
martin and um martin shorts slipped him
a note and he says if you if you deal me
in eight of spades you can [ __ ] my wife
and it was just like and there was for
them steve martin just read it and just
went
we're friends now
and they just love these like and he
says i've just we've just loved each
other ever since i've just been best
friends ever since and i just i just
love that
give me an eight you can have my wife
um but you know i just i i together i
like saying i don't i'm not a huge fan
of steve mine on his own to be honest
but those two together are just it's
just gold but yeah i really enjoy that
series i like him whenever he's by
himself but he can get too campy
sometimes the second
martin shorts with them it's just
it's phenomenal it just works doesn't it
just i wish they'd done more stuff
together over the years really i'm sure
they will i guess now this is coming
back and the fact that they did this
and it's already well since season one
it's been
i don't know if it's the number one tv
show or what but it's been very
prominent since uh it's been out which
is great
it's been great
and just asked a question i will answer
quickly andrew probably not because i've
been banned
on the on the machine i heard of another
channel i received things called the
machine and we did live videos and we
talked about conspiracies and mysteries
and all this sort of thing and i did a
video two years ago talking about um
uh the 911
and stuff
and um we got banned for hate speech
so um
i i've watched the video that i got
banned for
and i still don't it doesn't it's not
hate speech
but
um my pal who i did videos with is a
very conspiracy
nut i'm gonna go with nut i love him
dearly but he actually believes
everything he reads he once saw a show
that said about how um mermaids were
real and because he wasn't really
watching it thought it was true
and
i was telling him mermaids are real
there's no they're not okay here they
are i saw it it was an animal planet
um weirdly though he was right the show
was on animal planet
and but they got the animal plant to
google it animal planet mermaids they
got in loads of trouble for it and they
got fined and all sorts but they did
this like mockumentary
and he really wants to be bleep but
anyway um so he kept yeah he kept
bringing up these things that were a bit
far
out there through youtube um and youtube
banned us for it so at the moment i am
you know and on the machine
you may have just gotten banned
i mean there's lots uh you i do know
youtube if someone's got some
a lot of complaints
you know and they and uh they can voice
match the the guy that's really bad with
another channel they will ban both of
them
yeah
so let's hope this channel doesn't get
banned
yeah cause you got me on there bro i
keep telling your own thin ice with me
jesus and i'm in the center of the
screen what the hell's wrong with you
i'm not far behind i broke both rules
last week
uh-oh
yep
c-word and i forgot the other rule
that's already bad i probably i'll break
it again at some point oh well no you
you said covet and then you poked the
bear
so see i didn't break it this week this
time
no no no that's the other rule that's
right
don't poke the bad
dumb snacks
he doesn't want you to poke the bear
because it's three after nine and he's
got to go watch his soccer stuff
oh yeah
football
so now you've set me off
um i'm recording it it's okay
so we're all good but i do want to go
watch the mighty lionesses
do something that the men can't do
win a goddamn tournament
men like get beat by whales
and isn't whales full of the welsh
wasn't that a thing
yeah i mean i'm surprised
because
whales i think
yeah we did get people at us um
we're playing actually the old enemy
the lionesses are taken on germany
because it's called
foot ball
and i i i can't get past this point
enough
you use your feet
so
so i did not know this about stargate
but apparently uh the yorkshire geek
says the or i created cobot 19. i did
not know that don't say the c word
well you will get a problem
[Music]
i guess i missed that part in the
doctrine you know i don't think i was
mentioning much in doctrine you know
they they created the plague that wiped
out all of humanity in the milky way
galaxy
that was covered whatever 50 million
years ago
the first one covered 50 billion 50
million bc
but um thank you very much guys i didn't
tell you what i've got this week
they didn't
yeah really i've been really busy i
watched the gray man with um with a uh
pen
from a movie ryan gosling thank you they
actually they did joke at one point they
do go will somebody just kill this this
kendall
i was like
little dick
um it's really really good i enjoyed it
it's like enjoying it expensive movie
it's good
grandma's great yeah i really enjoyed it
my girlfriend watched that this week and
she just loved it yeah no it's a great
girl watch it if you get a chance um
every so often i'd be distracted by
something the wife would say something
they look back and goes well is he
beating up now and then like it was i
have to rewind this now it is it is just
the fight scene have to fight for
sightseeing but if you're not
concentrating you've no idea who's
kicking
and kicking somebody i don't know why
it's literally but um but no it's great
it's one of those films you've
definitely i think i'm gonna have to
watch it again
in america oh he's not very nice
yeah
that's i hope that that is so on purpose
that's the sign as well sometimes with a
good acting just go
i think this guy should have a really
shitty mustache and you just like go
yeah you should i just it works it's
just glorious absolutely
that's the premiere ryan reynolds uh not
ryan reynolds ryan gosling uh
called it a trash dash and an interview
or something and an interviewer says so
you talked about chris evans stash
earlier do you still think it's a trash
dash he said i'm standing by it and just
kept walking and it was great
i was at the premiere too so that was
fun
yeah but i don't think oh yeah that's
nice yeah um sit down my cousin and i
down like uh like the row h and the
chinese theater was so much fun
that is amazing that is cool so you can
throw popcorn at ryan gosling
no as a little stoned i might have been
eating a bunch of popcorn at the time
uh i'd love to do that that'd be amazing
what an amazing thing about to do if
that's just seeing someone actually like
good like that i mean for me it'd be
like if there's a new star trek movie or
something not to the jbl yeah
that would be so cool so let's go to
like a big like
sign up online and fast enough and it's
free
cool i'm going to do that
it won't be free for me i gotta fly to
america as well
um
premiere of something that would be cool
we got it we got a big audience down
here that was pretty good
um
cool but other than that i've just been
watching stargate because i want to do
the series three
preview we i'm reviewing each series
but i've realized it's so long since
i've watched him i need to watch him
again she's taking me forever
but
oh well i intend doing this channel for
a little while but before youtube vamos
and we do have to say that next week is
the channel's first birthday
um sidetrack is a year old
congratulations oh my god
it's been a year
i know i can't believe it
you've done a lot more than most people
can do in a year that's for sure
well i haven't done a great deal other
than talk crap at the camera i'll tell
you what i've gone through about four
different microphones trying to get a
microphone that works
i've got one now so that's good good
good good
i watched my very first video um not
long ago
[ __ ] man it's only 12 months old jesus i
wasn't very good but anyway
um
so but we've been going a year the next
year there will be cake so saturday at 6
me stormy and spencer who
it was just three talking that made the
channel happen
um i wouldn't have done it else are
gonna have a video and spencer has
promised now how she's not gonna have a
clue what this is about but i will send
you a clip later
okay spencer has promised not to write
on himself
with any permanent markers yes not to
fall asleep on screen
when did he fall asleep or did he pass
out because of intoxication i'm pretty
sure he passed clean out
there's a video and stormy wanders off
and i'm talking to spencer and um it's
i'll send you the clip to the the
i think i called it why we love spencer
video
the bits together
and um and he literally is you just see
him
yeah
does he fall off the chair at one point
and he was down for the count
he was drinking red wine he just got
more more drunk
yeah i'll do it he wasn't wearing
headphones or anything huh
honestly honestly i will send you the
link for the video in a minute it's the
funniest thing in the world um but
spence will be on the saturday and then
harris stormy i don't know obviously i
appreciate you all busy so if you if you
only want to do the one video next
weekend i won't have any problem but i
might still go live sunday and we'll do
like a star wars
chat okay oh yeah i gotta see what my
weekend's shaping up for next week
well if you can do the saturday that
would be amazing because
we got grandchildren
exactly and she's going to be a ball of
jibber jabber so i'm just
not sure so you're bringing her on the
stream no
no that's there's a youtube problem with
no
yes
there will be beer on next week's um
video andrew i've been told by shelley
so um but yeah stormy if you can do the
saturday that would be absolutely
phenomenal but obviously i know your
time is precious um but we will figure
something out for sunday if my wife lets
me as well that's the other point
um so
by the way i've been scrolling trying to
find i did a search on youtube for the
machine i think they've taken you
completely out of the search results
that wouldn't surprise me i mean i can't
find the even searching on the channel
name i can't find it
um i've been
um i'm blocked i cannot go live i cannot
upload videos
i might just delete the channel if i'm
honest
if it's causing that much grief
um and i i don't think i'll be back on
it i don't i don't think i'll be going
back to that
so uh
to be honest i if i don't spend on
strike people get angry at me talking
about fiction imagine how angry people
get talking how angry at me people get
when i'm talking about like conspiracies
and mysteries and things like that
people got cr people were threatening me
and i'm not joking yeah i mean
americans are very sensitive about
animal health
yeah
not just our legendary
everything anything and everything
people get i don't want no you should
get
i said you know i i thought on the whole
we treated it i tried i tried so hard to
treat it with a bit of respect
um
i thought you did a good job but i i i
think the other guy was just i can't
remember your buddy's name but i think
he
i saw it once and i'm going to holy [ __ ]
how is this still i really remember that
oh my god
because some of them particularly when
we were live i i mean you should have
seen some of the videos we did i had to
edit stuff out
um and i just had to edit it out and not
tell him
um because it was because some of the
stuff he came out with was just and i
love him to death he's one of my best
friends
but some of the stuff because he he
he half hears things and he believes it
and then he says it on a stream i'm just
like you can't do that
if you haven't if you haven't done the
research don't say it
i always think if i say something
controversial
i've done the research and i can back it
up but it's but it might be
controversial i will say things people
don't like but i will argue it
and
he didn't always do that
um but we we tried to show it with
respect
um but the one the video that got banned
wasn't even one of the worst ones i'm
not jesus you need to watch a couple of
the other ones
y'all missed these guys
but yeah i i literally got people
um
one guy i actually found out where he
lived and he sent me um a
message
with my address and he'd um took a photo
he got a photo of my house which i think
he got off um
google google earth i hope um but i'm
pretty sure it's off google earth and he
said i do know where you live and i was
like and that wasn't anything to do 911
that was something to do with aliens or
something
and i was like
maybe i'll stop doing this
but um i love talking about things on
that and i love the debate but some
people are just some people crazy man
they're just they're just crazy
um
uh matt people are upset by my
mat you have got twice the views i got
on that video so you win that you win
this round sir we're doing a video he
does a tuesday video and i do the
thursday video and
first week i tranced him i got so many
more views in him and i'm like
this week he's got like a thousand more
views than me
it's good competition
yeah that's a bit of fun it's a bit of
fun um
yeah i love the machines little before
so many laughs yeah i miss talking today
if i'm going to try and get mine here
and we'll just i'll tell you what we'll
try to just do some videos because we
don't have to always talk about
sidetrack sci-fi stuff on here stormy if
ever you want to get we'll get dave and
i will just talk about something else
sometimes i think just for fun we could
talk about woke [ __ ]
please don't
[Laughter]
oh i found that gunsmoke video it is
actually called the queue q-u-e-e
oh that's a coincidence
[Music]
um i did watch it i watched you sent me
a link i watched it it was quite good i
quite enjoyed it um but anyway i i'm
gonna go with the footy come on your
lionesses
come on england i hit the wrong side
come on
is that a good sign or a bad thing i
think he's having a heart
attack you call for emergency in england
this is nine nine nine is that that yeah
i don't know what the number is
if it goes to penalties i will have a
freaking heart attack
so because we always lose to germany on
penalties
so um you don't even know the penalty is
due so a penalty is at the end of the
game
if somebody commits a foul
in right by the goalie you get a penalty
or if a game is nil nil at the end and
it's got to be decided it goes to extra
time then it goes to penalties and
everybody has five penalties each
and we always lose
so if it goes to penalties
i will have a heart attack
sorry to hear that yeah
but hopefully
right
thank you so much harris there is a link
to your channel in i think and you're
saying you have a new video out today
yeah we've got a video
put out today and then we got a live
stream from uh our sci-fi guy on the
channel itself uh later today so check
out him cube down here wherever it is
okay very cool it's somewhere there uh
stormy our resident american you also
have your channel linked in there i
remembered
thank you so much
you're very very welcome uh i yeah i did
my job for once as the uh as the as the
creator and the planner
for once
um
thank you guys so much for spending an
hour of your sunday and getting up nice
and early and you know missing your
breakfast to come on live i really
really appreciate it we will see you
next week for our first birthday
very exciting then hungover i i might
mean harris we might do something on
sunday
we'll just talk crap and talk star wars
and i'll sit there going to the likes
dolls and you can just explain to me why
i'm wrong so that that i can do that
i've had someone ask me the politics of
star wars and i think three hours later
they were like
i think i get it now
and
it was it was a full three hours and i
blessed that person for letting me sit
there for three hours and
they were called
troopers for god's sake i mean come
on the og was a little a lot easier to
explain than the prequels i had to set
up a lot with the prequels by the time
we were there they were like all right
all right
there is no politics in star wars
you so much
see you next week guys
have a good bye
[Music]
you